john rush makes weird sounds all day
long it's his job and he's been doing it
for nearly 40 years yeah it's true if
this job is a lot of fun he's worked on
everything from ET to interstellar John
is a Foley artist to Skywalker Sound and
this is his amazing sonic studio this is
from Braveheart this is one of the
swords that we utilized it was a very
large sword which you use two hands on
so we want to make sure what we're doing
had that same sound so with this I can I
can make it sound big detail is our
business we want to make sure that
whatever we see on that screen we are
making the most honest representation
thereof sonically when I look at a scene
I hear the sounds on my head so all I
have to do is figure out well okay that
sounded here my head how do I actually
get that down on tape if you will the
place may look like a hoarders garage
but everything has a purpose even the
building is important it was constructed
just for the demands of Foley it has a
floor that goes all the way down to
earth for solid thuds and footsteps and
a splash pool that holds hundreds of
gallons of water just the thing to make
aquatic sound effects now in the back
room this is where all props are stored
and there is a method to the madness
believe it or not it's funny you see
this as okay little kids club right well
actually we use this in a video game
recently for a footstep of a weird
character so what you see is not
necessary get again that's the trick
feather dusters right just feather
dusters well not necessarily let's see
why guys thank you it could be a bird
and this is all the way from Helsinki
Finland from hi Keiko see the most
famous Foley artists in Finland it's
called Vita and well I'll have her sing
to you now you ready
first and foremost Foley is one of the
most fun jobs there can be and yet of
course it's most difficult good evening
there are more astronauts in the world
than our Foley artists but who would
have thought robot feet this is one of
my favorite props in Back to the Future
Marty borrows a scooter pulls part of it
off and turns into a skateboard when I
go to a movie if the sound job is
wonderful I get lost in the film in fact
that's what we all want you know we want
to go just have the popcorn to sit back
and be taken away whatever aspect where
we are and that's that's a wonderful
thing that's what I love about this
business
Oh